وفي مؤتمر صحفي قرر الحزب الاتحادي
الديمقراطي الاصل تجميد عضويه رئيس الحزب
محمد الحسن المريكي بسبب ما وصفه الحزب
بخروجه عن خط او الميرغني اييي الخروج عن
خط الحزب بموافقته على الاتفاق الايطالي
معتبرا ان توقيعه على اي ورقه لا يلزم
الحزب في اي شيء قرار التجميد بحقه ياتي
قبل ساعات على موعد توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي سيوقع حضور دولي واقلمه في
القصر الجمهوري في الخرطوم وافقت على
توقيعه احزاب سياسيه من خارج الحريه
والتغيير لكنها تدعم عمليه التحول لنظام
مدني ديمقراطيه فيما رفضته احزاب الامه
القوميه والتجمع الاتحادي والمؤتمر
السوداني والحركه الشعبيه التيار الثوري
الديمقراطي والاتحاد الديمقراطي وحسب
المؤتمر الشعبي كما ترف الاتفاق الاحزاب
المنضويه تحت مبادره نداء اهل السودان
وعلى راسها الحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه
والمجلس الاعلى للنظارات البيجو
والعموديات المستقله ودعم بعض هؤلاء الى
تشكيل جبهه معارضه بهذا الاتفاق
همم ذات المشكله اللي كانت موجوده في خمسه
اشهر طبعا هتتكرر ممكن نسحب في اي يوم
نصحى الصباح نلاقي انه همم نفس البيان
بتاع 25
على قياده همم الجيش على قياده الدعم
السريع افتكر انه فرصه
انه ما هتكون فيها فرص احمر
التجارب الكثيره اللي حصلت يعني ما بين
المدنيين والعسكريين
يبقى المدرب